E aí
há alguns anos atrás é na minha
adolescência no auge da minha
adolescência lá para os meus 18 anos eu
estava saindo para almoçar com as amigas
a pé e ali ainda na esquina o moço
motoqueiro passou e gritou mulher bomba
vai explodir ali naquele momento é eu
fiquei muito constrangida muito
constrangida mesmo tava ali na frente
das minhas amigas amizade nova queria
ser uma pessoa não diferente naquele
momento
né e acabou que eu fui para a sala
triste mesmo
é uma das minhas amigas me chamou no
canto desse Carisma aquilo não aconteceu
porque você é muçulmana aquilo aconteceu
porque você é uma mulher muçulmana já
aconteceu comigo também quando eu passo
na rua os homens me chamando de gostosa
os homens eu sofra sede naquele momento
por eu ser mulher e das palavras dela é
a coisa dessa história que eu mais me
lembro porque aquilo me marcou a partir
daquele momento eu percebi que eu teria
que ser mais forte que aquilo eu teria
que lutar duas batalhas há de ser mulher
e a de sermos humanos
Tá bom vou me apresentar aqui rapidinho
para vocês meu nome é Carisma eu tenho
27 anos eu tenho três filhos e eu me
visto dessa forma porque eu sou
muçulmana eu me visto dessa forma faz 21
anos eu tenho 27 Comecei a usar o lenço
com 6 anos
É eu sei o que as pessoas que estão
vendo esse vídeo tá pensando sobre mim
o que eu sou oprimida
o que a mídia tem razão Coitada de mim
o meu marido manda em mim eu vou contar
mais alguns detalhes que as pessoas que
me vem na rua não vão saber ela só vão
saber dessa primeira parte porque é o
exterior que fala mais alto
Olá eu sou graduada
Olá eu sou pós-graduada
e eu tenho dois cursos de educação
infantil com mais de 150 mil cópias
vendidas eu trabalho e eu tenho dois
e-commerces de vendas na internet
e essa segunda parte que eu contei aqui
para vocês ela perde para a primeira
parte ela sempre perdeu porque as
pessoas elas não enxergam que uma pessoa
tem além daquilo que mostra no exterior
e sabe por quê Porque as pessoas elas
não aceitam a diferença a gente sempre
aprendeu que a luta é pela igualdade
todo mundo tem que ser igual e na
verdade gente eu tô aqui para
desmistificar isso a nossa luta é para
que aceitem a diferença
é a riqueza da humanidade tá na
diversidade
bom então Parem de rotular as pessoas a
gente precisa parar de julgar a pessoa
pelo que ela faz de julgar a pessoa pelo
que ela pensa pelo que ela fala a pessoa
ela vai vai além disso muito além e como
que a gente muda isso eu tenho três
filhos e eu mudo isso com a educação
deles os meus três filhos entendem que é
legal ser diferente que eles são
tolerantes com as pessoas que são
diferentes isso para mim é o que mais
importa Afinal quem é igual a quem
Ninguém é igual a ninguém somos todos
diferentes i
bom obrigada
[Aplausos]